- I'm thinkin' the year
maybe 2004, 2005.
- OK.
- Football season
as a team, as a u—
[Door opens]
Speed. I bet that's
Doug f--king s--t up.
- We're rolling.
- Oh!
- Stop.
- What?!
- What's up, man?
Chris.
You doin' all right, man?
- You gotta be kidding me.
- Congrats, man, congrats.
- Appreciate it, appreciate it.
- The Hall of Famer in the flesh.
- Yeah, boy!
- What?!
- Woo, you look different.
- You look golden.
[Laughter]
- There's a gold hue around you.
- What's happenin'?
- You're looking good.
- You told him to come up here?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's awesome.
- We're goin' to get McDonald's
after this.
Who's the better receiver
sittin' right here?
Think about it.
- Who's the better receiver?
- Yeah.
-What kind of question is that?
- Well, I think T.O.'s one
of the top three receivers
in the history of the sport.
- That's a f--kin' lie.
Let me tell you why.
- Tell me why.
- He's not the better
f--kin' receiver.
He had the better cards
dealt to him
and took advantage
of those opportunities.
- How do you figure that?
- Can I finish?
- No, first of all,
I'm gonna stop—
- Can I finish?
- No, I'm gonna make you stop right there—
- But listen, listen—
- Because I only played
with Steve Young three years.
- Who? Who?
- Steve Young, three years,
that's it.
- I don't care
who you played with.
- Outside of that,
you had Carson Palmer—
- Listen.
- A Heisman Trophy winner.
- Look where I—
- That doesn't matter!
- I was in Cincinnati.
You played for the 49ers!
- That has nothin' to do with it!
- The Cowboys, the Eagles—
- They weren't that good,
the 49ers, though.
- Wait a minute!
- The 49ers weren't that good.
- These are awesome
organizations.
When I came in,
I was in the s--t bowl
according to everybody else.
- Whoa!
- And I made the most of the cards
that I was dealt.
- Bro, I could've played
for the Cleveland Browns
and did what I did—
- So basically—
-So don't tell me—
- I'm not finished talking.
- I played with the Buffalo Bills—
— And got off.
- I'm not finished talking.
- I played with the Cincinnati
Bengals with you and got off. - OK, Jesus f--king Christ.
- Was there one part
of the game
any part of the game
that you stole from each other
where you were like, damn—
- I couldn't.
I couldn't do anything
he did, honestly.
- No?
- His DNA, his makeup,
his skill set is completely—
I mean, night and day,
completely.
The stuff he would do,
the stiff-arming people
never f--kin' worked.
I would go the opposite way
- [Laughing]
- Cuz I was more of
a finesse player.
My favorite thing
to watch T.O. do
him and Brandon Marshall
dudes playin' bump-and-run.
Let's say I'm tired—
fourth quarter.
They have this f--kin'
tug-and-pull where they invite
the contact and wait for you
to get a hold and pull by.
How in the f--k?
- Yeah, I know. I've seen it.
- I tried it in practice
one time.
I'm right there in the
same spot. Can't get off.
- So, you're on the Bengals.
What was the day
when he joined the Bengals?
- I had lobbied for that big-time
with Marvin, with Marvin.
I said—I asked Marvin,
you know, a lot, man.
"We really need to bring T in.
I think it would help us
offensively tremendously."
- Who was your receiver coach,
God bless his soul, that year?
- Sheppard, Mike Sheppard.
- Mike Sheppard at the time.
- Dealing with you two in
meetings must've been amazing.
I would've loved to have been in
a meeting with you two.
- Nah, it was easy.
When I'm workin', I'm locked in.
- Yeah, I know you are.
I know you both are.
- Yeah, I mean, again,
people may think
that we're uncoachable
based on the antics
and how we, you know, go about,
but when it came to football
like, literally—
- That's what nobody gets to see.
- Right, I know.
- In the workplace, when it's time to work.
I remember he's tryin'
to get me to slow down
on Fridays, remember?
- Yeah.
- Man, Fridays.
Man, I'm out there balls to the wall.
- You know how Fridays are,
you know?
- It's a chill day.
- It's time to taper down.
- I know you were. I know. Right.
- Man, listen.
- I'm like, "Dude."
- T was like,
"What are you doin'?"
I'm takin' scout team—
- Yeah, I'm like, "Bro!"
- And this is well into
my 10th, ninth year.
I'm just out there movin'.
- Yeah, the perception is wrong.
- I remember just—
I'm just growin' up. Think about the
Hurricanes in the '90s.
- Yeah.
- And that's what I grew up
watching, so as
a kid growing up
the game of football
was about having fun.
When you're in the NFL and you
misbehave or they do something
you don't like or you
don't follow their rules
what's the first thing
they take from you?
- Money.
- Money. Because that's what
they think you value the most.
- Right.
- But for me, the money was gonna come.
- Regardless.
- Money comes and goes.
It's gonna come regardless,
which is why I never stopped
doin' what I was doin'
because the money was great.
It was awesome. But when I didn't
have any money, this is the way
I played the game of football,
which is why I never stopped.
- Even with—and
to go a step further
you talk about the Hall of Fame
and everybody realizes
when you're in the Hall of Fame
obviously, there are
financial opportunities
well outside of that,
and so I was well aware of that
and I had some Hall of Famers
even told me—they was like
"Man, you gonna mess up
these opportunities."
You know, for me,
I'm just like Chad, you know?
Money comes and goes.
If I had to, you know,
if I'm put in a situation
where I gotta choose money
over my family and friends
I'mma choose my family
and friends all day.
And it was just, it was
sad to see how
the media, again,
they didn't allow themselves
an opportunity to know
who we are as people
and they went
into the perception
of who they thought we were
and again, we
just went out there
and we just had fun
with the game.
- It makes it more interesting
to have the villains
to have someone to talk about.
There has to be a bad guy.
- There has to be.
- They have to, but it's unfair, like you said
because, again, how can you
justify Tom Brady doin'
or sayin' some of the same
things that I've done—
- Right.
- Showing emotion.
- Right, yelling the
F-word at the stands.
- Right. Exactly.
I've seen him curse out coaches.
I've seen him berate his own teammates.
- Yeah, right.
- But he's looked at and upon as
a leader, a champion, you know?
- You know what,
if I had to do it again
honestly, to restart
and had to do it again
I'd do it the exact same way.
I wouldn't change s--t.